all right I'm sort of depressed that we
have to do this again but I'm okay with
it and I'm gonna keep doing it until it
sticks and it may never stick and it'll
just be an ongoing conversation and if
that's the case then so be it
Bernie Sanders democratic socialism is
not communism and in fact Bernie's
democratic socialism isn't even
socialism it's actually social democracy
which is a form of well regulated
capitalism the number of emails and is
actually going up that I'm getting about
this because bernie has a shot at the
nomination because more and more people
are paying attention to Bernie Sanders
the number of emails I get about Bernie
communists this Bernie socialist that
communism isn't invalid socialism isn't
invalid there is a lot to discuss and
debate and explore about both but Bernie
Sanders is running a campaign of social
democracy now before we dig into this
I know Bernie often says he's a
Democratic Socialist I wish he wouldn't
he may be a Democratic Socialist but he
is running as a social democrat
this is a type of capitalism common in
northern Europe and certain other
countries Donald Trump calls Bernie a
socialist-slash-communist the Czar two
different things
Bernie is running as neither now I tried
to do some basic definitions so that we
could at a basic level compare and
contrast the three ideas there are no
perfect definitions because there will
be those who envision a specific type of
socialism when they say socialism or
when they say communism they envision
some prototypical type of communism but
I think that this is pretty good as a
starting point for us social democracy
is a capitalist economy strongly
oriented toward social justice and we'll
talk more about that in a second
socialism is a system of social
ownership of the means of production and
communism is a system of government
ownership of the means of production
these are not perfect definitions but
this at least helps us draw some lines
so when you look at this no matter how
you define this stuff universal
healthcare does
make a country socialist
medicare-for-all is certainly not a
guarantee of communism or socialism
capitalist countries with strong welfare
policies are not socialist and they are
not communist Bernie Sanders does not
want to abolish private property Bernie
Sanders does not want to mandate
socializing ownership of the means of
production Bernie wants to democratize
the workplace where individual companies
are structured in a more egalitarian way
taxation is used to redistribute wealth
to some degree so that no one's standard
of living falls too low this is really
pretty uncontroversial stuff and there's
a long list of countries Denmark Sweden
Norway Finland and others that have a
socially democratic systems similar to
what Bernie Sanders is proposing now
there's something very interesting about
social democracy versus socialism of
Social Democrats versus actual
socialists there are strict socialists
actual socialists that are often very
much against Social Democrats who
propose what Bernie Sanders is proposing
why social democracy makes capitalist
countries more equal social democracy
makes capitalist countries healthier
more viable better functioning social
democracy strengthens capitalism it
takes the edge off of capitalism strict
socialists are sometimes unwilling to
see things in shades of gray and they
get mad at Social Democrats because they
say social democracy will make people
more satisfied with a capitalist system
which we want to go away making it less
likely that there will be a desire for a
revolution in which a country actually
becomes a socialist country now there
are many socialists that are more
pragmatic and they realize we are more
likely to eventually get to socialism
from social democracy than from where we
are today so there are some socialists
who from a pragmatic point of view
welcomed socially democratic reform
now let's get back to our definitions
for a second just to clarify that even
these definitions are controversial and
I understand that there are some who
will say you know David your definition
of social democracy is not really social
democracy its welfare capitalism and
that's something else some will say you
know the real difference between
communism and socialism isn't that in
one the government owns the means of
production and in the other the people
own the means of production the real
difference is that communism is
necessarily revolutionary and it
includes a one-party government and
one-party rule whereas socialism need
not necessarily include those things so
I understand that these are not perfect
definitions but this is a framework to
think these things through but the
important takeaway is that by any
reasonable definition Bernie Sanders is
not running on a communist platform and
he's not even running on a socialist
platform if he is a Democratic Socialist
then the platform he is running on is
not one and that is the really important
takeaway that I hope we can all sort of
integrate and assimilate into our points
of view what if I told you that you
could read eight books in one afternoon
that's essentially what one of my
favorite apps allows you to do it's
called blinka stand you can try it
totally free for a week and get 25% off
a subscription when you go to blink east
comm slash Pakman blink Asst takes
thousands of best-selling non-fiction
books gathers the most important info
and insights from each book presents
each book to you in the form of a
condensed ebook or audio book that you
can consume in just 15 minutes there are
only so many hours in your week blinka
snakes it possible for you to absorb the
most valuable takeaways from nonfiction
books that you otherwise might not have
a chance to read I've just finished
listening to upheaval by Jared Diamond
Jared Diamond a tremendous author whose
work I've previously recommended
excellent book looking at some of modern
history's biggest national crises to
figure out how different countries ended
up in such precarious situations you can
use blinka stew get through a topic
quickly
and efficiently it's really useful if
you just want to explore a certain topic
but don't necessarily want to commit to
reading the entire book about whatever
it is and a premium subscription is only
about eight bucks a month which gives
you unlimited access to every single
book that they offer they have books on
politics economics philosophy science
you name it you can try it out yourself
totally free for a week and get 25% off
if you decide to subscribe just by going
to blink is comm slash Pakman I've put
the link right underneath this video
like the rest of us I bet you're going
into 2020 thinking about what you didn't
get around to in 2019 and your goals for
the new year if you want to work towards
being your best self in 2020 understand
more about the world around you and make
sure that your time is well spent
then blink astiz for you